[music playing]
When you watch "Truck Night,"
you see all our start lines
and finish lines are
a nice black line,
and you're probably thinking,
how do they paint the dirt?
Well, we don't.
It's black woodchips,
is basically what it is.
MAN 2: Team comes out and
preps all the courses, perhaps
that green hill,
puts the chevrons,
puts the poles up, and
tries to make the courses
look as cool as they do.
MAN 1: And generally, after
somebody drives over it,
or finishes a race, or starts
the race, it's all torn up.
But here on the slag heap, it's
not torn up at all, because all
our contestants are loco.
And they jump the
finish line, over it.
So what is this place that we
film "Truck Night in America"
in?
It's actually a
working kaolin mine.
This is kaolin.
It's a strange, white,
kind of clay stuff.
[laughs] Gets everywhere,
I'll tell you that.
MAN 1: All right, drivers,
you're looking down the barrel
of 600 feet of kaolin.
When it's dry it's
like chalk dust,
but we've been hosing it down,
and it's slippery as ice.
DRIVER: Oh!
DRIVER: My god!
MAN 2: We use this
material for whiteout,
and also the kaolin climb.
When it has a little
bit of water on it,
it becomes very,
very, very slippery.
Come on.
DRIVER: Oh, no!
MAN 1: It's that close, Bender!
MAN 2: And that's why you
see some of our drivers
struggling up something
that seems to be quite easy.
The kaolin I'm holding
my hand was formed
50 to 100 million years ago.
They traced the name back
to China, where the name
kaolin means high ridge.
It is, in fact, the name of
a place, or a small village,
where kaolin was
first discovered.
MAN 1: He's not
going to make it.
MAN 2: No, no!
He's so close!
We're in Georgia, and
kaolin is one of Georgia's
largest natural resources.
Oh-- Man, that is slippery.
So there you go, a little
bit about the kaolin mine
that we call home here at
Truck Night in America.
Unlike the real Stonehenge,
we call this Carhenge.
This is where you get your first
glimpse of the car graveyard.
MAN 3: It stands
twice as high, and has
twice as many cars as season.
It took 4 and 1/2 weeks
to build this monstrosity.
MAN 4: And we add new
cars after every show,
from all the victims
of the green hell.
MAN 3: He is stuck
on the car graveyard.
Oh, no.
Looks like the car graveyard
has claimed another victim.
Now, you gotta pick a solid
line here on the car graveyard.
If not, you'll slice a
time, or end up on your lid.
Don't roll it!
Oh, man.
And this thing's constantly
shifting every time we run it.
The weather can play
a big role here.
If it rains, these
hoods get extra slick.
But getting to the summit
means you're only halfway home.
Yeah, you got two
big holes coming up
in this thing you've
got to watch out for,
and an even bigger
one on the other side.
MAN 2: Only the best
drivers come up and over.
Yes!
Car graveyard.